- Forgive me Father, I have...
sinned.
Well, I think I have. I'm not sure.
So, it's about cats, umm...
I just like 'em
better than I like even me
and I have found that
I can understand now what they're saying.
(meow)
And then...
And...
(short meow)
and there's
(long meow)
I guess it was because when I was young,
I found it very difficult
to talk to girls.
And then this ginger cat who was a girl
came along and I just found I could,
I could talk to her.
Taylor Swift!
I remember her TV show
and she reminded me of a cat.
But, I felt bad for her
because she has this
stupid looking cat, ya know,
it's ears folded down.
I tried to tell her this isn't fair.
She's a lovely, lovely girl.
She deserves a proper cat
and I'm thinking of, maybe
buying her a proper cat
and then just sort of delivering it to her
one day when she's not there.
You know, so that she
comes back and she sees
it and she goes, "Ohh! Proper cat! Wee!!"
Oh, it's you!
(meow)
(cat noises)